Speaker 1: It's great to welcome Bob Kuttner
to the program today, who is coeditor of the
American Prospect magazine, also chair at
the Heller School for Social Policy and Management
at Brandeis University.
I really appreciate your time today.
Thanks for being on.
Pleasure to be with you.
So I've been interested in the idea of economic
nationalism for some time.
And one of the I guess where we can maybe
start is whether there is some inconsistency
among some on the left on this issue, because
I'm still developing sort of my sense of this.
But there is a sort of global egalitarianism
that I see from many who, like me, describe
themselves as being on the left and progressives.
That seems to stop short when it comes to,
well, we should have an economy that prioritizes
the American worker.
We should have trade deals that are best for
the United States.
Is there a conflict or an inconsistency there?
Speaker 3: Not necessarily.
And I think it's really important to start
out by defining what we mean.
And I think economic nationalism means two
different things that sometimes get conflated
rather sloppily.
So good.
Let's start with that, please.
So if you are a Roosevelt progressive and
you're not a neo liberal and you think that
capitalism is predatory, and in order to have
a system that is efficient and socially just,
the government has to be involved big time.
A democratic government has to be involved
big time in regulating capitalism.
That means that you have to put limits on
globalism, because if you have what we've
had for the past 30 or 40 years with the WTO
and the use of trade deals to undercut the
regulation of capitalism, you can't regulate
capitalism.
I mean, banks can go offshore and we don't
care whether products that we import are made
with slave labor.
You know, the whole litany.
Sure.
Economic nationalism, in one sense of the
word simply means that we have to regulate
capitalism.
And we, for better or worse, is the nation
state.
There's no global economy.
You can't regulate capitalism with a republic
of naphtha.
You have to regulate it with the United States
of America, where where I'm a citizen and
you're a citizen.
Speaker 1: And to some degree, is that also
just the practicality of legal framework and
just sort of the limits of what any one group
can do?
I mean, I know we have we have NATO.
We have you know, we have these organizations,
but it doesn't get sloppy.
Speaker 3: Well, it's about sovereignty.
Yeah.
If you want to regulate capitalism, you need
a degree of sovereignty.
And the state is sovereign and there is no
sovereignty globally except to the extent
that you have treaties.
Right.
The other kind of economic nationalism of
which Trump is the extreme example or maybe
Hitler's the more extreme example is America
first or Germany first and screw the rest
of the world.
And so where it gets tricky is on the question
of how you make it possible for the whole
world to regulate capitalism in the interest
of ordinary people.
And since we don't have a global government,
that means you have to have agreements, you
have to have treaties.
This morning's New York Times reports that
the E.U. is going to have climate tariffs.
If you if you try to export stuff into the
EU that are made with processes and products
that pollute, you're going to have to pay
a tariff.
Now, that's a good kind of nationalism.
And Biden is talking about doing the same
thing.
So the tricky part for me, anyway, because
I'm you know, I'm a third world guy as well
as a new dealer.
How do you extend this so that the whole world
is able to regulate predatory capitalism?
And interestingly, that is what was attempted
in nineteen forty four at the Bretton Woods
conference where the architect of that conference
with John Maynard Keynes, he got a do over,
you know, they got it wrong with the Treaty
of Versailles in in nineteen nineteen, where
he was a junior economic adviser to the British
government.
He quit in disgust, in protest.
And then twenty five years later, he was the
chair of the Bretton Woods conference.
And he said we have to orchestrate the rules
of the global system so that every country
gets to regulate capitalism in the interests
of workers, in the interests of citizens.
Now, here's the tricky part.
You get down to cases.
So if we think that China is predatory, we
we think that China violates human rights.
We think that China violates the rules of
the trading system where they subsidize and
they dump and they steal intellectual property
and all that stuff.
And so we're going to have some we're going
to have an industrial policy and we're going
to have a.
National security policy, where certain technologies
we're not going to allow China to acquire.
That seems pretty sensible to have an industrial
policy.
Where do you draw the line?
And is that an industrial policy for the United
States or is that an industrial policy that
the EU and all of the democracies are part
of?
And then if that's the case, who gets the
business?
So, for instance, there are three major chip
companies that are not Chinese that make state
of the art chips once Intel.
The other two are European, Ericsson and Nokia.
So do you have a cartel?
Do you carve up the market or do you say we
have one set of rules for companies that play
by democratic norms and market norms and a
different set of rules from China, which doesn't
play by market norms.
So where it gets tricky is around the edges
where when you get down to cases and here's
Vietnam, third world country, a dictatorship,
but not as nasty a dictatorship as China.
And a lot of stuff gets outsourced to Vietnam
by American companies.
And these are very poor people who need the
work.
This is where it gets tricky.
And so you have to have trade agreements that
are very different from the kind of trade
agreements that Clinton and Obama made that
have human rights in them, that have some
concern for the ability of Third World countries
to get a foot on the ladder so that they can
have decent living standards for their for
their people, but not simply turning the world
over to multinational corporations.
Speaker 1: Yes.
And I wanted to I mean, let's talk a little
bit about trade, if we can, because the the
the concept of free trade being a net positive
is rooted in some pretty traditional economic
ideas of specialization and relative efficiencies
of producing and exporting products.
And it really goes back to a lot of that that
traditional economics.
And at the end of the day, as you're pointing
out, sometimes the best way to control conditions
when it comes to labor and products and imports
is you bring you bring the supply lines domestic.
But at the same time, then you're depriving,
as you point out, a lot of people around the
world of the ability to better themselves
and better, better their economic situation.
So how how would how should we interpret all
of that and sort of parse it?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Let me address what you said about trade being
efficient.
And then let me respond to the second question.
Yeah, well, here's a conundrum.
David, Ricardo, etc..
Theory of comparative advantage trade is efficient
because of specialization.
OK, but hold on.
We have known ever since Roosevelt and before,
really, that free markets are not efficient.
Right?
Markets priced things wrong.
Markets priced carbon wrong.
Lord Nicholas Stern said global climate change
is history's epic case of market failure.
Right markets price labor wrong because corporations
have the power to really exploit workers,
markets, price, all kinds of stuff wrong.
They priced housing wrong.
So question, how is it that we need to have
a managed form of capitalism domestically
because markets priced things wrong and then
somehow when you cross borders, all of a sudden
markets price things right and the answer
is they don't.
And this gets into power relationships.
You want Third World countries to be able
to get jobs and gain market share, but you
don't want them to exploit their workers.
So let me give you an example of a trade deal
that I think was a pretty good trade deal.
Yeah, there used to be something called the
multi fiber agreement.
It was a worldwide cartel for textiles and
apparel.
And the idea was that we're going to give
every country that wants to export textile
products into the United States a quota.
And the economists that this is terrible.
This is a cartel that violates the free market.
And the other side of the argument was, well,
if you if you just eliminate it, China will
get everything because China will underprice
everybody and all these other countries will
get the short end of the stick.
Speaker 1: Common argument, huh?
A commonly heard, commonly repeated.
Yes.
Speaker 3: So what they did for a while, this
was in the last two years of Clinton when
Bob Rice was secretary of Labor and actually
had some influence.
They they made an agreement.
Cambodia was the model country.
And the agreement was if you follow international
labor organization norms and you give workers
the right to organize.
We will give you additional quota slots under
the multi fiber arrangement, and so thanks
to that, the labor movement got a foothold
in Cambodia and workers actually started being
paid better.
It didn't hurt their market share.
It helped their market share.
And then, of course, the Republicans come
in and they just blow away the whole thing.
So there's a middle ground.
I guess this is my punch line.
Yeah, there's a middle ground between absolutely
free trade, which is a mirage anyway.
And Trumpy, an economic nationalism, which
is a kind of negotiated trade where you have
some norms, where you have some standards
and the standards are not just a code word
way of screwing the Third World.
And a lot of the Third World diplomats have
made the argument that the West is hypocritical
of the West.
Talks about the International Labor Organization,
talks about labor standards.
That's just protectionist.
And again, you've got to get down to cases
depending on the particular rules that are
negotiated.
It can be protectionist or it can be in the
interests of workers everywhere.
So you have the case of the Bangladesh horrible
Bangladesh fires where this is a very poor
country.
The job that workers don't die in fires when
you don't do that as a covert way of depressing
their market share, you've got to get down
to cases.
I guess that's the point.
Speaker 1: The last thing I wanted to touch
on briefly relates to the coronavirus pandemic.
We've talked to economists, social psychologists,
all sorts of different folks about the impacts
that they see as a result of the coronavirus
pandemic and what we've sort of learned learned
from it when it comes to an economic nationalism
perspective, globalization, supply chains,
et cetera.
What do you see as the big takeaways from
the pandemic?
Speaker 3: Well, I think and it's not just
a pandemic.
I mean, the unfortunate thing about the pandemic
is that it moves this center stage and gets
people talking about it.
So I think it demonstrated that reliance on
supply chains, a lot of which are in countries
who are not necessarily our friends, is risky
economically and risky politically.
The question is, which stuff do we want to
make in the United States?
For what reasons?
We want to make it in the United States for
industrial policy and technological leadership
and jobs reasons we want to make in the United
States for national security reasons.
And where do we draw the line?
Take take solar cells.
America was once the leader in solar solar
panels.
China basically undercut America's pricing.
So a lot of technology, they're now the leader.
If we take it back, try to take it back with
an industrial policy, that means we're paying
more money in the short run for solar panels.
Right.
Which are more expensive if we're trying to
get rid of carbon.
So it's complicated.
You cannot settle this at the level of grand
theory.
You have to have some basic norms.
We want a positive sum game that helps American
workers and also helps the third world.
And then you've got to get very specific.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and often I think that missing
from the conversation where we hear just this
very vague and general bring the production
back home, there's very little discussion
of the impact that that would have on the
prices of many of the things that we're talking
about, as you point out, with solar panels,
which is a decision that could be made.
I mean, the decision could be made.
Here's a list of 10 areas where we believe
it's worth paying more.
Here's how much access would be reduced for
the American people as a result of that.
But we believe it's worth it.
Speaker 3: Well, and by the way, this is what
Japan and Korea and China all did at earlier
stages of their economic development.
I mean, Ricardi and economists would have
said to the Japanese, why in the world do
you want to invest in an auto industry or
a steel industry or a machine to an industry
because you can get it cheaper from the United
States.
And the Japanese answer was, well, depends
on what your time horizon is if your time
horizon is this year.
Yeah, but if your time horizon is 50 years
or 100 years or a thousand years, we want
that industry in our country because that's
good for our economic growth and for our jobs.
So you can't just take a snapshot at a point
in time and look at the China price.
Look at the US price and say, oh, well, obviously
we've got to buy from China.
So it really it's it's it's tricky.
It's complicated.
And you've got to get you've got to get into
the details in the particulars.
Speaker 1: Without question.
Without question.
We've been speaking with Bob Kuttner, who's
coeditor of The American Prospect, also chair
at the Heller School for Social Policy and
Management at Brandeis University.
I really appreciate your time today and your
insights.
Speaker 3: Thanks so much for having me.